and now what we need to get this last
segment man I really wouldn't creepy
crazy fake news of the New York Times
this is crazy do it believe all women is
a right wing trip how feminists got
stuck answering for a canard oh I should
have known it was the far right come no
one ever said that we should believe all
women how absurd that's actually not
true oh boy do I have a ton of stories
here's one from NPR February 6 believe
all women that's been the rallying cry
of the me to movement oh here's
something from National Post inside the
quote believe all women refrain has
become the unquestionable undercurrent
to the me to movement yeah yeah yeah you
get it it's everywhere we believe all
the survivors all right all right all
right now let's see the lie they try and
push forward they mentioned that Joe
Biden has been accused but will you stop
ground jump down a woman with no
corroboration beyond beyond
contemporaneous accounts charges a
powerful man with a decades-old crime
hmm doesn't it sound mighty close to
kristinb Ozzie Ford's complaints against
Supreme Court nominee Brett Kavanaugh
yes yes yes it does wait that's the
problem with artists they start the
article by shooting them what yeah yeah
well no they're trying to deflect
they're trying to deflect by by flipping
the narrative in driver you gotta have
the memory of a goldfish to fall for
this stuff but people do here's a chess
yet this time many liberals who've
championed the me to women seem
skeptical gotcha
Tim Graham executive editor of News
Buster's where is the me to movement on
this story what happened to their rigid
believe all women boiler boilerplate Fox
News host Tucker Carlson the infuriating
the sickening hypocrisy of the media and
the professional feminist movement
believe all women no they don't
why does invite adviser Kellyanne Conway
three magic words believe while women I
didn't hear an asterisk I didn't see a
footnote believe all women so long as
they're attacking somebody along with
President Trump believe all women so
long as there have a college degree or
better or are are for abortion in the
ninth month Wow Kellyanne spicy in fact
quote believe all women does have an
asterisk it's never been feminist
boilerplate what
we are witnessing is another instance of
the right to crying what it imagines the
American women's movement to be spend
some mind-numbing hours tracking the
origins of believe all women on social
media sites and news databases as I did
and you'll discover how language like a
virus can mutate overnight all of a
sudden
yesterday's quotes suffer the insertion
of some foreign DNA that makes them easy
to weaponize in this case the foreign
intrusion is the word that proves it she
said it because she read the news I read
the news to lady check this out NPR
believe women that's been the rallying
cry of the me to movement yeah it was
they were all saying it we didn't nobody
made that what we did make this up you
guys made this up it was your phrase
yeah and now it's okay all insertion was
all the rage during the Cavanaugh
hearings no the NPR story from February
2018 is well before Cavanaugh Cavanaugh
was what October 2018 yeah so no I'm
sorry that is not the case all right I'm
pretty sure yeah let's get the correct
date cuz I come a lot I can be wrong I'm
not perfect let's see it was it was all
the rage during the Cavanaugh hearings
when Senators Kamala Harris to mazie
Hirono had their regard for de Blasio
for dr. Blasio's credibility elevated by
Fox News pundits to universal gender
credulity their actual words I believe
her became believed all women so what
was the date on Kevin I it was September
28 D that's right
and as and what's this story from the
National Post what's the date on this
one February 6th 2018 the National Post
indeed the believe all women refrain has
become the unquestionable undercurrent
to the me to movement
wow that's well before red caffeinated
Cavanaugh that's interesting I'm glad
you brought this is called media
gaslighting yeah note gaslighting is in
I'm late knows to gas lighting is when
they try to make you think you're crazy
or they just present fault fake facts to
rewrite history there's what the New
York Times is trying to do no we never
said believe all women we're infallible
it's you who's wrong it's not right who
did this yes so you're technically
correct gas lighting is a psychological
tactic where they sow seeds of doubt
covertly in a targeted individually make
individual making them question their
own memory perception or judge
boom yeah that's what they do the media
does this and like I said if you've got
the memory of a goldfish you'd fall for
it I don't I was like no I remember
people saying believe all women so I
looked it up and sure enough this claim
fact-check false the me too at the very
at the bare minimum if you want to argue
about the origins of believe all women
wear this this this is a lady right he
was running the story Susan that's right
her argument is that she looked up news
archives to find the origin and it was
the right who injected all and changed
the phrase okay well then you're
ignoring NPR or the National Post that's
far right so here's what she says the
all was injected I believed her became
believable women that's literally the
hashtag former Fox News contributor
Morgan Ortega said in a February twenty
nineteen in february twenty nineteen
there's a great search function on
twitter and you can search the hashtag
believe all women for those of you who
don't believe that's what the democrats
had in the case of Cavanaugh is there
literally a hashtag well kind of no no
there is that's great
meaningfully tracking hashtags on
Twitter is a confounding chore even the
professional data scrapers are consulted
it's a very interesting rabbit hole
Pablo Morales Henry digital archivist at
Harvard University's Schlesinger library
which maintains a collection of more
than 30 million meet to related tweets
told me nevertheless let's take the
Ortega's challenge as she noted Twitter
is a search function that while hardly
great does at least crudely reflect the
site's use especially by its most
popular users who are most likely to
spread a hashtag far and wide frig's for
instance type in black lives matter make
America great again and you get
bottomless well of references type in
believe all women for 2017 when the me2
movement took off in October and you
gets you get several dozen references
followed in 2018 the year of the
Cavanaugh hearings by many more but
here's the thing
I felt the hash tag is by by a wide
margin used mostly by its detractors
except the me2 movement started around
October 2017 in about four months five
months NPR the National Post and many
other outlets were saying quote believe
all women is the rallying cry of the me2
movement so what's your point
detractors started hearing that and
started
criticizing it and many people
criticized it it sounds like your only
argument is that you were wrong not that
that's not what the the feminists were
actually saying simply because you were
being criticized by people for saying
believe all women doesn't mean that the
right invented it
it seems that believe all women first
appeared on Twitter in late 2014 and
three tweets by an Ontario Midwife a
Toronto educator and longhua a lifelong
learner and Jena and Kayla twins from
Ottawa who plan events in their spare
time
combined following fewer than 4,000
followers then in the fall of 2015 then
in the fall
oh and 2014 I see Hillary Clinton posted
a tweet to every survivor of assault you
have the right to be heard you have the
right to be believed to which we need a
broader echo alleges that Bill Clinton
raped her in 1978 responded on Twitter
Hillary tried to silence me okay
conservative editor David French was a
large following retweeted miss Broderick
at once attaching the hashtag believe
all women followed by for question marks
the breath was on the Ember where is the
believe all women crowd on this believe
all women unless the case damages a
leftist narrative blah blah blah as it
happens the canard blown into the
bonfire by the right became accepted
truth in mainstream media from NPR to
the New York Times to The Globe and Mail
in Canada with pronouncements
characterizing believable women as the
rallying cry of the me2 movement the
order of the day and a formula for
miscarriage of justice if ever there was
one but hold on didn't she earlier just
say it was all the rage during during
Kavanagh is she trying to convince us
that this is the whole trite thing
or that's large Democrat the Democrats
like ups like it's basically like she's
explaining why we're the Democrats now
you know now that that you know Biden's
up on the chopping block it's like where
are the Democrats that's what I'm seeing
it feels like she's you know a
Republican going where all the Democrats
now where are you guys at why aren't you
it's leaving all women now I'll tell you
what she's saying it doesn't make sense
perhaps it's true that believe all women
was first a hyperbolic criticism on the
left okay okay I'll accept that that
means the left championed a movement
that was created in jest to criticize
them and they didn't realize it instead
of running around screaming something
that was created to mock them
okay is that what she's arguing that's
not that am I wrong about is that that's
that sounds like what you saying right
that sounds right to me
okay well let's read how she ends this
listening what is this you know you know
what I can't stand about a lot of these
journalists how they don't write
conclusions it's like do you know how to
write so let's just jump back she says
the prefer wait wait this is why the
preferred hashtag to the me2 movement is
believe women okay you know what I'm
done reading this thank you it's clear
it's clear what she's trying to do I'm
over it too whether or not anyone
created me to movement in the media you
mean to tell me that NPR's who is this
who else a Chang I believe that's a
female girl to me she didn't know what
what believe all women was so where it
came from kind of condescending I think
what we can real and I think the
National Post is written by a dude is
written by Jo O'Connor then we have this
we believe all survivors look at this
protesters march around the Capitol to
the steps of the Supreme Court
undeterred by the reigning cold some had
posters that read we believe all
survivors others stood in silence
outside Dirksen Senate office building
with the words believe women right on
their hands we believe her so perhaps
it's fair to say and this is during the
Kavanagh that believed women was and
believe all women was you know maybe a
combination if that's the case fine so
be it but it is true that protesters had
been saying believe all survivors we
believe all women I suppose it's
possible that the left is so unable to
understand their own causes when
conservatives criticized them they
assumed that was their actual cause and
then championed it and went out
protesting we with saying we believe all
survivors
that's not that's not a good narrative
to to entertain that's really
embarrassing yeah it is a great
apparently that's the argument I guess
no no we were tricked we were tricked I
guess you were so I think the
interesting thing is it's definitely not
a right-wing trap you know if the
argument is that one guy said believe on
women question mark question mark and
that sparked the hashtag believe all
women for which the left picked up and
used no one said a trap they were
criticizing you and you didn't realize
it and year old
and you rolled with it yeah well it's
even worse nah man this is just one of
the stupidest things I've ever read yeah
i'm i read that title and i was laughing
and now that we've gone through it it's
not even funny anymore it's it's it's a
it's a whole lot of writing to try and
erase what believe all women was and
what the activists were saying yeah
exactly it's like even even you know
what I'll be I'll be fair and say you
know my initial assumption was that
believe all women was sparked by
actually does she mention she says uh
three years ago was it let's see where
is it here we go 2014 three tweets did
they actually they did they did okay
believe all women it was not started by
the right she actually admits it yeah it
was originally started by some small
Twitter accounts and she tries
downplaying their following to make it
seem like it wasn't made by them
Toronto educator and then someone took
that and used it against them I think
the story is stupid who is she trying to
convince I don't know any stories
dominance herself it's dumb she's dumb
everything is dumb I feel stupid or
having read it yeah I lost my cue points
i I have nothing to say to this yeah I'm
normally all jolly and smiles I'm sad
all right well so depressing article
I'll conclude by saying it is a sad and
desperate attempt yeah it just makes
them look stupid but it is just one
opinion piece by one person so fine I
think this is just oh it's not
indicative or representative of any was
anything other than this one person's
desperate attempt to blame the right for
something they didn't do I'm actually
upset having actually done the segment
on it now ever having read it no I think
it's great I think it's good okay here's
why here's why I think it's good okay
we're gonna look on the bright side here
please
try so I think that her showing us that
she thinks that we're all super freaking
forgetful and stupid is really
illuminating because that's what they
think of us all the time it just came
out in this article that's good to know
I appreciate it
can I say oh there you go thanks for
checking out this clip from the Tim cast
IRL podcast we do the show live Monday
through Friday at 8 p.m. if you want to
catch the full show tune into this
channel subscribe hit the like button or
check us out on iTunes and Spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode
you